the five women nominated for Best
Performance by an actress in a leading
role are Kathy Bates in misery Angelica
Houston and The Grifters Julia Roberts
in Pretty Woman
[Applause]
Meryl Streep in postcards from the edge
[Applause]
Joanne Woodward and mr. and mrs. bridge
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to Kathy Bates in
misery
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'd like to thank the Academy I've been
waiting a long time to say that I would
like to congratulate all the nominees
this evening especially those in this
category their work continues to humble
and inspire me I would like to thank
everyone associated with misery Columbia
Pictures Castle Rock
Andy Scheinman Rob Reiner for giving me
a chance I'd like to thank William
Goldman for bringing the wonderful crazy
Annie Wilkes to the screen and Stephen
King for thinking of her in the first
place
I would like to thank Jimmy Caan and
apologize publicly for the ankles and I
would like to say that I really am your
number-one fan Jimmy I would like to
thank the cast and the crew of misery
they're incredible they were a pleasure
to work with and I would like to thank
my friends watching from New York at the
sea palace on 9th Avenue and I would
like to thank my my family my friends my
mom at home and my dad who I hope is
watching somewhere I would like to say
thank you thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]